voilà un petit hommage ainsi averti
pendant longtemps à vis à vis à vis avec
les journaux ne cessent de parler d'une
ville qui est en passe de détrôner las
vegas 2 2
battre tous les records de popularité
c'est nanterre en terre est une ville
admirable visiter nantais sa faculté à à
bientôt envoyez à voir des panneaux sur
les routes quand on arrivera à nanterre
en visitera ça comme provins la cité
médiévale et on tend surtout beaucoup de
nanterre fasse bien sûr il ya des
frottements à l'université et les
frottements la faculté et on parle
surtout énormément de des appariteurs
muscler ses les appariteurs musclés sont
les braves gens qui ont été engagées
pour ramener un peu de calme lorsqu'il
était étudiant est un peu excité un peu
énervé mais on ne sait pas exactement ce
que c'est que ces à parité en muscles et
nous en avons 1 dans le studio qui a
bien voulu venir ici on peut pas dire
que vous soyez le shass des appariteurs
musclé parce qu'une association qui n'a
pas de chef
un chignon vous vous arrangez entre vous
c'est un c'est un groupement créé un
roulement bien je dois dire que vous
êtes quand même un pari de remuscler
titularisé car tout et vous vous appelez
gabriel ghislaine applicables oui bon je
peux vous appeler gagné coup tellement
cher gaby ont opposé des petites
questions quand même sur ces appariteurs
musclé d'abord vous êtes là pour amener
le
le cam bon d'accord mais comment est-ce
qu'on vous recrutent comment est ce que
vous êtes engagés et bien c'est très
simple on recrute les appariteurs
musclées parmi les culturistes les
athlètes les danseurs mondains les
antiquaires oui tout ça mais tous les
gens qui sont musclés qui sont je veux
dire musclé pas naturellement qu'ils ont
un peu forcé sur le muscle qui enfin si
on travaille et les pois les alter à
l'aller l'inter les pois les choses
comme ça oui voilà alors ben problème du
recrutement est résolu quand vous êtes
eh bien on est on est on est cinq très
exactement 5 5 pour toute faculté d'aix
la c5
je peux vous donnez les nous il ya jean
chrétien katchou oui y'a bambi je les
connais celui qui passait chez nous tu
dans le il était
il est et c'est lui qui chantait je suis
né pour ça alors il est venu à paris
pour nice 1 et il ya sucre est aussi
secrète sucre c'est un il est à égalité
c'est costaud liens secrets tous les
officiers et puis il y en a il y en a un
autre là mais qui n'est pas du fait
qu'ils c'est un appariteur aussi mais
enfin il était appariteurs avant qu'on
arrive c'est instinct un type qui
s'appelle monsieur marche pied c'est pas
un professionnalisme et un ancien oui
c'est un tipi les patchs et vous glacer
pour fait pas partie dans disons le
carrément il fait pas partie de l'accord
porte un film est la même là quoi voilà
c'était il y fait pas partie des ailes à
il en est pas lien n'est pas une des des
appariteurs musée maintenant imaginez
qui est je ne veux produire une révolte
mais un peu d'excitation à nanterre
comment est-ce que vous opérez qu'est ce
que vous faites vous tous les feux les
étudiants se mettent en colère ils
chahutent on a chacun en dessous des
locaux donnez nous des locaux bas vous
arrivez alors on a chacun sa méthode
oui on est chacun sa maison de motards
et comme j'ai la mienne je repère le
meneur je repère voyez un des meneurs
surtout si si le meneur il est l'écran
s'il est blond au cinéma ce jeu leur
terme
si vous êtes un parfum jeu dur et oui
c'est ça la festa et alors les gars
leurs jeunes repères je m'approche tout
doucement dans un avis dont je file un
coup de pied nationale pic vous vu que
je suis là je ne joue pas alors je leur
père je m'avance et craque je le seul un
tir à walfadjri l'immobilisait les bras
c'est une sorte de luth produisent des
fois oui mais alors là je les lâche
parce que vous n'êtes pas méchant pour
amener wii la wii puis je vais vous dire
c'est un peu la trouille
oui d'accord bon bah écoutez je vous
remercie mon cher gaby je te présente
inverse
or voilà bien qu'entrant quand vous
pourrissent nous allons nous tourner
maintenant vers un autre invité
qui nous fait là je